[Applause]
all right well welcome everyone um we're
really sorry uh Gina Rondo couldn't make
it today but my sincere hope is that she
will manage to keep all of us doing our
necessary work here with her duties in
Washington um so good afternoon I'm Jeff
Brock I'm the dean of the School of
Engineering and applied science and it
gives me great pleasure to uh to bring
today the second of our series the
dean's invited speaker series um these
are a new series that we've inaugurated
to try to bring uh members of our
community the larger Yale Community who
are highly placed in Industry into
conversation with all of you and with
the larger Yale Community um so many of
our alums have made their way to the top
of the industrial World in one role or
another they have incredible stories and
you know our guest today really
emblematizes that probably more than any
of our alums
um so I'm really pleased to welcome CC
wayi who joins us in part in addition to
this Grand Event to receive the Wilbur
cross medal this evening from The
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
uh let's Round of Applause for
[Applause]
that so just a couple of words about
CC's trajectory he was he received his
graduate degrees PhD here in the
1980s uh just before I arrived on campus
we just missed each other um and uh he
then went on to a role as a research
scientist and working at Texas
Instruments semiconductor Corporation
ultimately found his way to Leading
Taiwan semiconductor manufacturing
company or tsmc which has been in the
news and which you no doubt have heard
of if you're here um so I won't go
through all of the twists and turns of
his career and the other academic
institutions which may deserve some
measure of credit for his arriving at
this uh at this sort of Pinnacle in
Industry um but
really my goal is to have just a an easy
conversation with uh Dr wey here and to
hear about some recent uh collaboration
that he has been involved in with the
United States and how that reflects uh
his worldview um and so you know we'll
just engage in about 25 minutes or so of
conversation and then I'm eager to open
it up to this wonderful crowd and thank
you again all for coming now let me
welcome CC way
[Applause]
okay now maybe you'll turn down the
volume for a minute so we can open our
Diet
Cokes
exactly
all right so um I have the honor and
privilege of opening it up here today
but I guess I'm just curious how you
came to Yale how you saw Yale as a as a
direction you wanted to pursue and what
you think it gave you in terms of your
trajectory
forward that's a good question you are
wearing a yell tie so it must have meant
something to you uh well starting with
this tie um this is a only chance I can
wear a tie with proud I mean that's you
know if I wear this one in my company uh
a lot of people will protest you know
because they graduate from the different
school they think uh you know they are
the best uh anyway here here is the
best look why why I join here uh it's
interesting this is because of it's a
name brand you know that what is called
name brand uh the Harvard Y and uh
Stanford MIT those are the name brand uh
so when I receive I apply many schools
when I want to have a graduate study and
one day I received the admission and I
still waiting for other school to give
me the reply but then my family my
brother especially he said hey young
brother this is a Yale is that the same
as in the newspaper is a har Yale I say
yes he said then why what are you
waiting for just go over there I mean I
say well you know I am still waiting for
Kanon or those kind of a school he said
what the Manon Manon is a is a fruit
don't go over
there so uh well I accept the you uh
Joker side actually Professor m is one
of the reason that I decide to join you
and uh because of I have uh my uh School
uh
Professor uh Dr C he is a classmates of
Professor Ma and uh I think that
Professor Woo is a nice professor
then Professor M must be as good as him
in fact it's a better it's a best and I
learned a lot from Professor Ma and uh
today Professor Mar's wife is here and
I'm grateful to them uh pin
yes and then to tell you the truth uh
when I was
uh you know study in
Yale uh it's a endless work a lot of
pressure and a long working hour so I
thought say this is here of my life I I
need to get out as quickly as
possible and I tried but you know I
failed of course you you still had to
stay five years and something like that
and in between I uh talk to Professor
Parker uh we are in the same group I say
uh I say Professor Parker how can I get
out quickly then he look at me he said
you don't you don't get out uh have you
ever enjoy year I say how to enjoy you
yeah you know in in my life is the
headen hard H the tunnel to backton
Center the way the life in backton
center and never ending uh so he look at
me he said have you ever listened to any
speech in the law school I said what the
hell why I need
to I want to graduate that's all right I
mean that's you know so he did not give
me the right answer so I to be patient
but finally finally what I got from a
year as got a PhD degree but I also very
proud to meet one Young young lady that
I fell in love with and then finally
become my wife uh my wife is here
Jessica and then with her I have three
lovely kids okay one of them is with me
Terry
uh okay I tell you the truth I got what
I want I had have a degree I have my
wife and then you know the life goes on
right and U I thought that would be a
Rosy picture ahead but actually it's not
if you work on the semiconductor
industry you had to work hard um it's by
Nature because of this semiconductor is
a very important industry finally we
knew that but you know 40 years ago is
not you 40 years ago uh double e is not
so uh let me say that is not so popular
uh now today is more important okay I
got all my story in
here I was telling CC CC earlier that
semiconductors are hot look at the uh
presence here today um so what would you
say about the kind of the American
culture resonates with you in terms of
developing um creativity
productivity why might you be inclined
to work with the US government to to
develop this
partnership that's a good question uh
actually there's a lot of rumor say that
tsmc had been pressured by US government
to come to us to build
aair to tell the truth it's not not
really that story in Taiwan we start to
see the
limitation of uh the number one
limitation that in Taiwan I I have is a
talented people the limitation of among
of talent people and uh to tell the
truth us is a is a country that with a
most Innovative talented people here uh
like you gu are okay um very
Innovative uh very uh kind of U wild
dream
driven uh people and uh especially for
the ivd student they always being
trained to be the leader so you guys
don't think something small you are be
the leader in your industry in your
career one day and so now talk about why
tsmc want to be five in the US simple
because of us will have a huge amount of
a talent people that I can look for and
we can have a some select of the talent
people to join
tsmc uh in US as the same time the US
also think about the government also
think about the semiconductor is very
important
it indeed is very important because this
is a
semiconductor is a center of every
technology you name it in the future you
name it you want to have a have a more
advancing Medical Care you need a
semiconductor you want to have
autonomous driving you need you need a
semiconductor you want to have a AI
application in every industry you need
semiconductor so US Government suddenly
realize that I say suddenly because they
never talk with a with a tsmc now they
talk very
often um so I actually I expect to uh
have a sh occasion that secretary
Romando here um but anyway so
finally um I mean why we choose you us
it's not we choose us this is a natural
choice because you need the talented
people here okay and by the way US
Government also promis to help tsmc to
build the Fab in Arizona so we choose it
we like it and we have some problem no
doubt you just read the newspaper but
then we will overcome all those kind of
thing we took it as a as a kind of a
learning cycle and then we are going to
build a m app in the US and welcome you
guys to join by the
way so you mentioned the um
characteristics of the undergraduates
and other and graduate students that we
train uh in terms of
leadership what would you see as
challenges that universities face now in
terms of Technical Training what kinds
of technique should we be emphas sizing
in terms of
curriculum technical that's interesting
I never touched that area for more than
years you know now all the days I use my
lip
service uh same here by the
way that's why we sit here um actually
uh my wife Jo with me say that if I
cannot speak it out I can ask my uh my
kids to help me uh to deliver the uh the
speech
um in under graduate I let me use one
joke one time I talk with Professor
Baker so Professor baker said that uh as
a professor he has to treat the
undergraduate student very well because
most of them will be the leader in the
industry uh for the good student when
you have a good track record uh
um when the student have a good track
record they will become Professor so
they will become his colleagues so deal
with them politely when the student with
a bad record uh the best goo they will
be the industry leader they were they
will donate the money to the school so
be nice to them
also for those graduat student ignore
them because of you know they are
useless
sometimes okay now Joker side um I
always think the best IV Le so uh the
school actually to train the future
leader that's very important I'm not
very good at the technical to be frank
with you I'm a mediacal student uh when
Professor Mar me the school it's a
mediacal so I'm the one that graduated
but uh you know this school the Year
this school what train the future leader
you look at how many of us President we
have from this school we are the best in
the do school right um engineering I
don't know I mean that we're getting
right yeah but then we will be the
leaders in the industry you know look at
me I don't need to have a very good scho
but you know I still can be the leader
don't worry you will get it uh by the
way the trick is that you had to live
longer
yeah so stay
healthy okay so you've teed up my next
question which is at what point when you
were working through your career did you
see opportunities for leadership what
made you choose to head in that
direction as opposed to research and
Engineering well the answer is very
simple I'm not good at
research so by natureal you have to
choose another route right uh to be
frank with you uh in my career we have
to be
humble uh we had to be humble during my
whole career so I know a lot of talented
people they can do much better work than
me in terms of
technical uh but I'm not too bad either
by the way okay I have a few papers and
about 30 to 40 uh uh patent 30 to 40
papers and speeches but then I'm not the
very best of it
however
during your career you continue to be
humble uh
humidity and uh you had to
be
uh love what you have doing with your
work that's a trick that's a trick you
got to be
happy only when you are happy you can
work hard but how to become happy why
how you are going to love your work you
have to find the pleasure inside your
work that's a trick if you cannot find
the pleasure don't do it you know change
to another company or change your boss I
don't know H
usually but in reality you cannot change
your boss right so you try to find some
pleasure with your work and then you are
become happy and then you work
hard I I always believe that everybody's
a wisdom almost equal you are not much
smarter than other people but working
hard enjoy it and then you can walk all
the way through and by Nature you are
become the leader of the your group and
then become the leader of a bigger group
and become the leader of a company like
like me right now um you know
to be frank with you I am lucky all the
time whether you believe you or
not so your advisor uh TP ma was one of
these Larger than Life sort of warm
personas and and we miss him dearly
probably there were nevertheless moments
when you had doubts about your chosen
direction as we all do as graduat
students what were the things that kept
you
going what can you offer this group in
terms of motivation for the the hard
moments yes one motivation because when
I was a graduate student the life is
tough right I mean that's I have to work
quite a long hour all the way through
the night so uh the motivation is to get
out of this school as quickly as
possible
and then I will have a better life right
uh the same motivation that when I was
working in TI I'm a engineer so I say
what what I what I am doing I still work
day and night so I want to be promoted
to manager so I will have a better life
so once I get the manager manager a job
I say oh boy I got to be a VP so then I
can relax
uh so I was a VP in uh in
tsmc then I found out God boy I work for
a very tough boss Dr Morris Chen so I
said oh boy I mean that's a I got to be
a CEO to get rid of that's
Nightmare and then I start to regret
that I that the nightmare never
disappear uh so the motivation
motivation is uh usually you think the
future is better but uh
uh it's not
really so just give you a good advice
okay guys uh be realized that in your
life you always have a dream and the
dream come true but not the same dream
as you
have all right well I think that's
that's what I wanted to ask ask our
friend but I'm sure you have many
questions you might want to uh pose to
CC I don't know if there any any
hands anyone want to raise a question
yeah over here thank you
Elizabeth um the vast majority of US
military planes have Taiwanese chips in
them um and the semiconductors were made
in your company and I'm just wondering
um where you think the supply lines for
um these chips will evolve in the coming
years you you can you can
either agree or decline
answer that's an
interesting question that I uh don't
have a perfect answer I mean that you
are talking about the uh like the US
government official talking to me that
you know uh this is a related to the
National Security or related to the
resilience of the uh supply to the
US uh to be frank with you in my point
of view uh this semiconductor industry
is a
globalized uh every country doing what
he can do the
best uh but among them the biggest uh
let me say that the big the
strongest country in semiconductor
industry is the
USA okay you guys don't get misled by
the
newspaper by all the uh rumors say that
all manufacturing Taiwan is are very
good and uh blah blah
blah the Str strongest country in
semiconductor industry is
USA now the US
is kind of a putting manufacturing aside
for a while but if us decide to pick it
up quickly they will and why I say the
strongest country in semiconduct
industry is because of all the process
all the technology development you need
the very Advanced
tools and all the advanced tool
originated or being manufactured in the
US that's where it become the strongest
are using the photo as a one of the
example uh today the most advanced photo
to is a
euv uh is anybody know what's called
[Music]
euv that's all and all other people
didn't know okay now let's say anybody
who did not understand UV stands for uh
except my wife
okay okay good I mean that's a that's
kind of a very uh small wave length
tools and the C part of the
UV is in the US the light source the
light source to generate such kind of a
very short wav length is from the US no
doubt about it and uh using tsmc as a
example I use a lot of apply materials
tools I use a lot of them researches
tool and K Teno and a lot of and uh a
lot of software from uh uh like a mental
graphic or now it become a seens or um
okay I forgot their name I'm sorry for
that but Cadence and then sypnosis and
those
guys those are from us without them you
cannot develop or you cannot design any
product so uh uh part of the reason I
can answer uh Jeff's a question why
choose us as a partner of course this is
the best country for the semiconduct
industry what years I can choose so if I
have have a Cho have a choice us is a
number one place I will choose produce
enough chips inside us uh takes time
okay so be
patient that's the same answer I answer
that US government
officials be patient be
patient okay uh there's another one over
here hi um I'm Frank so my question is
um even though us is you know one of the
more higher Tech countries in the world
what made Taiwan such a fertile
ecosystem for tsmc to to develop there
versus being in the US
originally
oh you're talking about the ecosystem
for the whole manufacturing of the
semiconductor uh the sem answer be
patient it takes time to build up right
I mean that the tsmc has been in Taiwan
for 30 years uh the whole ecosystem
including uh to set up a building to to
uh set up a Fab uh the construction
worker to be specific and also the
facility worker and everybody and also
the chemical Supply the raw material
supply it takes Taiwan for more than 30
years to be mature and so I would
expect uh I don't think the US need 30
years us is can catch up quickly because
of this is the best place in the world
that uh you have a lot of talented
people and all the key is talented
people and so when us decide to focus on
the semiconductor
manufacturing it will be uh catching up
quickly and uh you but it takes time it
takes time not 30 years of course much
shorter than
that all right next
question uh first want to say thank you
very much for coming it's really a
privilege to be able to listen to you uh
I also ask uh so since you made the
transition from being a engineer to a
manager uh how did you know like like do
you have any advice for being able to
make that transition from managing
circuits managing people and you have
any advice regard regards to
that tell the truth managing people is
very tough uh you might want to uh read
the book that been written by President
Sal uh he a guy invented
e and uh how to manage the people please
read his
book uh I regret a lot that I did not
read his book and be and being promoted
to a manager's job I like to manage the
machine because they don't
protest uh
um managing the people are very tough
because of uh for example if they are
not have a quarrel with his wife then
his his temper become very bad how did I
know I mean that yesterday he's my nice
uh good friend and today he show his
face on me so I don't understand that so
I give him a hard time so usually you
change for from uh technical role to
become manager role you had to pay more
attention to people's daily
life which is a very
Dynamic and so is a very tough job and
so if you are very good
manager uh I always ask my guy if you
want to be promoted to be a manager you
got to get
married
you know how to manage your family then
you are become a good
manager no joke I I tell them that if
you are not married I will not promote
you to the
manager
here um if and how do you see tsmc
essential encountering Chinese Rising
Global um technological influence and
and semiconductor
industry the question is uh from my
point of view to look at how uh
China I don't make a public comment on
China by the
[Applause]
way
to be frank with you guys I was not
allowed to uh give a speech uh without
go through my legal department so I
prepare nor for you because they say
that CC you probably have a big moue so
we don't we don't allow you to talk
about something uh one two 3 4 5 6 7 and
finally I decide say I have to keep
silent uh so
I don't make a comment on my customer I
don't make a comment on us China's
political confrontation I don't make a
comment on China um I have a lot of
customer in China by the way uh they all
use
tsmc and besides uh the one being put on
The Entity Leist was my second largest
customer and I lost start but anyway uh
no thank you no
comment okay another one over here um hi
um so I'm sure throughout your career
you've had a lot of like mentors and
sponsors um I'm curious to hear like who
some of them were and why you picked
them
out I did not cat who some of your
mentors were and why you sought them out
so I pretend I don't understand and her
question um for the mental
work
mentors like TP from the TP M starting
from tpma first right uh I learned a lot
from all my mentors per se uh I have a
four person in my life
uh the first one tpma I learned a lot
because of a TP is smart and never be U
harsh on me even my uh academic work is
a mediacal but uh uh of course in later
days uh when I being uh in the VP or
senior VP or the CEO of uh tsmc tvma
start to change his uh uh uh record on
me and become
better
but actually I learn from TP on very uh
he's very
patient and
uh very uh kind of
instructive and he also show me how to
write the good technical
paper uh that teach me a lot and then
after TP and Professor Baker of the TP I
joined
tsmc and there's a talent
uh B also uh in TI I have uh my uh
manager is called rajel haen rogel haen
he passed away when he was very young um
but in the i e
iedm has a best student paper award in
name of Roger haen so they called it the
rogel haen best uh
student
award uh that tells you that how
important he is uh his achievement it's
very smart usually do you know that in
our life before okay I tell you guys
after you graduate and join a company
you are start to write the weekly
report and nice to be a CEO because I
don't need to write a wicked report
now
okay so I have a long time for for more
than 30 years continue to write a weekly
report rajel haen is the one that never
cut paced on my weekly report into his
weekly
report okay he usually he read my weekly
report if he did not understand he
called me into his office and then uh he
asked me to sit right beside him and he
start to use his his own world to ride
the wickly and asked me to really say
that this is exactly what you say and he
catch
up the idea very quickly and then one
day he become the senior fatoh of TS of
TI his job grade is higher than his SP
he boss is a boss and direct report to
the ti
president so that tell you that house SP
he and he also teach me a lot he gave me
a lot of uh uh not instruction but just
say why this one become that that why
you did not see it oh my God so I have
to go back and work hard uh Roger hen
but finally I met with a very TP one if
you want to call the mentor uh Dr Morris
Chen uh he is a founder of a
tsmc and I learned from him a lot but he
still around so I don't want to make any
com
in so you've spoken about Ai and how
your semiconductors are necessary for
this a woman in the front spoke about
weapon systems and how semiconductors
also necessary for that do you think
it's feasible to introduce greater
tracking of where semiconductors are
going of what they're being used
for
Semiconductor uh it's because of us
China's a confrontation so become the
center of that confrontation but to be
frank with you without that actually
finally the people will realize the
semiconductor is is a center portion of
all technology including whatever you
want to name it including uh in our life
like U I like to use in the medical as a
one example I don't like to use in the
military or some kind of a
confrontation uh in the
medical
uh in the medical
field uh I want to make a joke of my
wife she only trust the guy with
experience right so when you see a
doctor you want to see a experience
doctor am I
right okay but look at it um to to give
you some idea if a doctor is a 50 or 60
years old are you going to let that guy
to do the
operation do you know that the people's
hand is not
steady
do you want to do the experiment just
hold a laser pointer to the wall and see
how steady it
is okay now here comes the question if
you want to do the
operation which the the the hand is some
kind of uncertainty and then you let
that doctor to cut it not me I mean that
you know I trust that uh is everything
controlled by the semi conductor then
I'll Trust it okay so in the future I
would like to say the surgery will be
done by the machine the machine is
controlled by the
semiconductor that's one thing and the
other thing is what is called experience
experience that mean you learn a lot of
a skill by years and you have to
remember by the way so I will say that
if you go to the hospital to see uh you
got the fluit so you you tell the doctor
say I got the fluit I have coughing I
have a running nose and everything blah
blah blah and so the doctor will say
okay sit right there measure your
temperature measure measure your
heartbeat and then uh be very patient
with you for half a for half an hour and
then write down some medicine for you I
don't need it I just using the AI to
collect all the FL example in this area
and then the AI will make a judgment say
that what the age you are is a is a male
or female and what the symptom what kind
of a temperature body temperature what
kind of heartbeat what kind of a blah
blah blah and then they also look at are
you in New Heaven or you are in New York
or you are in Washington DC and so the
FL in that area of the people the
symptom look like a what and finally get
a conclusion and write down the medicine
for you and the accuracy will be 90 or
95% so you don't need a doctor you just
type into the
computer and then 90 or 95% of accuracy
you still have 5% to take 10% right then
you see a doctor and then doctor say
it's not working for this one and the
computer ask it so what ear then type it
into so the computer continue to
remember continue to educate
itself and so finally I don't need a
doctor to see when I I have a FL I don't
need a doctor to do the operate you know
to do the uh operation
surgery I don't need a doctor to give me
some advice uh like I'm
overweight and the AI will tell me said
Mr way you are overweight for 5 kilogram
you better to do the
following and whether I follow it or not
then I have to wear a smart watch and
then the watch will major my heartbeat
major my temperature send it to uh
computer and computer give me a warning
say that you are not listen to me so you
have better watch out you only have how
many years to
live then I get nervous right so I start
to follow the uh instruction but anyway
in the future semiconductor will be the
key to in our life something like that
uh yeah maybe have time for one last
question
yeah first of all thank you for the
great talk and inspiring us uh of course
uh every process in the semiconductor
manufacturing is very important but F
fast decade people talk a lot about the
miniaturizing the semiconductor and
integrate more and more chips inside of
more and more transistor inside of the
single chips but as a like 7 nanometer 5
nanometer 3 nanometer like that but uh
now we will facing the limit of the
miniaturizing the uh process so what if
your inside or
Prospect which process will attract
people's attention after the
miniaturizing and integrating the
transistors good question is there any
actually your question should separate
into the is there any limitation at
all okay and what we are doing to deal
with it I give you a story when I
graduated from y I joined a TI in 19
actually at the beginning of
1985 uh I graduated in
1985 but uh you know I want to walk uh
quickly because I have a family to raise
so uh at the beginning of the 1985 I
work in TI I read the paper published by
the IBM they call it one microme
technology and they say you know not for
long that were reached the limitation of
the semiconduct dor device uh if you
look at it look at it look at the bean
free pass of your electron at a kind of
different temperature you'll find out if
a channel lens shorter than your be free
pass there's a lot of a limitation
there's a lot of high electron there's a
lot of physics inside so they say
quickly P5 mic is the end of the
semiconductor
technology okay and since then now today
we are at 3
nanometer and so the people ask me the
Sams we ask ourself inside tsmc is there
any
limitation so what happened after 3
nanometer you know 2 nanometer so what
happened after 2
nanometer 1.4 I tell you the truth you
just Time by 7 in while so so one of the
one of the uh occasion I answer the
question the people asked me what
happened after the 1.4 nanometer I say 1
nanometer and what happened after the 1
nanometer of course
7 something something like that and they
keept asking and finally my answer is
why should I care because I retire
already
all right thank you again
CC thank you guys pleasure thank you for
coming thank you please
welcome enjoy some refreshments outside
and let thank you
here one last World don't forget to join
tsmc after you
gr
[Applause]
[Music]
you